so after driving 60 miles to
we have driven 60 miles back we're in
the parking lot of taco bell because we
just watched
tennant it's great going to the theaters
missed that how long has it been
six months six months at least seven
months i think february was the last
time right
wow um yeah so
i think our food's ready
thank you so much so being back at the
theaters i thought was a great
time are you still you still got me yes
okay
it's like way behind i gotta like turn i
know i want you to turn it's a good
angle
but this is a good angle not a good
angle the light is shining right now
my first impression of watching this
movie was
i really like this movie it's also
i uh i don't get this movie
at all and i'm so glad olivia was with
me the entire time
because she had no problem understanding
this movie
she's taking many physics classes she's
generally just a lot smarter than me
because the movie moves as she's nodding
the camera as the movie moves
at such a fast pace like there's so much
editing and there's so much cutting
around this has like a structure of
action and then info info info with a
lot of cutting around and a lot of
sounds in the background
it's a loud movie while there's dialogue
playing and there's plenty of times
where you can't even make out the
dialogue
because there's so much sound around in
the background like man
the mixing on this is kind of rough but
even when i could understand the
dialogue clearly
i still don't quite get what they're
talking about though even though i can
now hear it thank god for social
distancing space and because i had her
explaining stuff to me
throughout but it did get to the point
where i'm like i'm asking too many
questions
i'm just gonna have to wait after the
movie's done the thing was though i
think that's actually a testament
to the movie of how you can actually
really like it even
if you don't get it watch the new
rockstars video on the way back
i'm still like i get it more i'm still
kind of confused though
so i really liked john david
washington's performance i thought
robert pattinson was really cool in the
film man that guy can act
uh the music was instantly captivating i
love the music in the film all
complaining about adr
and or audio mixing throughout with the
dialogue
the sound design is actually really
great still i love the action scenes
like there's some
truly unique action scenes in this movie
no
watch where you're [ __ ] driving yes
my car ain't gonna hit the action scenes
are just so damn unique
you start thinking of like kind of
inception but he's definitely doing
different things working with this
inversion
theory everything about how that was
captured was brilliant and i do overall
as much as i thought like there was
a lot of most of the scenes are just a
lot of info i didn't really feel
connected to the characters
i know you did i know i said oh i'm so
glad you did
oh sad for you i was just so focused and
just trying to keep up with the
information
it looks like elizabeth debicki's in
this movie and she's
kind of like the i i imagine kind of
like a film noir
female character um without trying to
give too much of the plot away
she does a really good job in the film
too she's probably the biggest heart of
the movie she's the one with the most
character richness i felt a little bit
disconnected from like the character
experience aspect a lot of that could
also fall on the fact that i was
pretty freaking confused through like
majority of this movie it was kind of
like the matrix for me
major is my all-time favorite movie and
i didn't get it at all the first time i
watched it but i still
really love the the mood and experience
and the visuals and i can feel that this
is the kind of movie that even though i
don't get it
i still really liked it for the mood
experience and the technical
landscape of it i was really gripped by
all of that and even though i didn't get
it i'm still glad
we drove over a hundred miles in total
just to watch it
i know that even if i watch this at home
and didn't get it i would regret not
having watch it in the theaters on imax
for that visual feast
kind of like the matrix that even though
i don't fully
get it right now it's one of those
movies i'm going to become
obsessed with trying to understand and
i'm sure the more i rewatch it the more
i'm going to love it i really recommend
it
it's his most cerebral and like like
really like even though it's completely
fiction it really feels like he's trying
to ground this as much of a physics
reality as possible i'm glad olivia was
there to
keep me updated on the whole time i was
there and but uh
i i still really recommend it and i and
i love going to the theaters to check it
out
i really did all right let's go eat our
taco bell now
you know when movies when a character
says
english please and then they explain it
for an audience member who might not get
it
i could have used that like 25 times in
this movie and it would have made it a
lot easier to watch what was going on i
don't know how she got it so well it was
like 20 minutes into the movie she's
like i know the plot twist
and then she got it these grilled cheese
burritos with substitute
with beans is delicious if you don't eat
meat by the way
oh ken brown he was really good too
he was good i'm looking at the mic not
the camera he's really good too